[Music]
all right we're breaking into our
regular programming to take you to the
lebanese capital beirut where we have
reports of somebody being killed in
gunfire of course this comes after a day
in which crowds have been gathering to
protest asking for the removal of a
judge
related to that case where they were
investigating the beirut port explosions
let's go now i believe to zain our
reporter is standing by live for us in
the lebanese capital zaina what can you
tell us at this point
well a lot of tension in the streets
just look around the streets are now
empty
uh two hours ago when the protests began
the protest that you mentioned which was
called for by shia political parties
against the lead judge in the
investigation into the beirut port
explosion we kept repeatedly hearing
bursts of gunfire a few minutes ago we
heard two loud explosions which were
likely rpgs and they were fired in the
air now the area in front of us is a
front line the army the security forces
have have cordoned off the area around
taiyuni now tayuni is a neighborhood in
beirut which was really a front line uh
during the civil war which ended in 1990
and it still remains a front line
between two opposing political factions
one of them is the amal movement as the
one of the shia parties which actually
called for the protest today and the
christian lebanese forces party you can
see ambulances in the street sami you
mentioned that one person has been
killed and up to eight people injured
this is what we understand from hospital
sources if ali just get out of the way
for the car
people are afraid they are leaving their
work picking up their children from
school there's a lot of panic in the
street because this is a country that
that really has been on the edge further
divide as you can see here parents
picking up their children from school
people are really afraid
he's saying that there's a lot of
gunfire near the school and they're
firing rpgs and he's saying there are a
lot of
dead and injured again we cannot confirm
this but what we do know from hospital
sources is that one person is dead and
eight people are injured the source of
the gunfire is not known but as you can
imagine both sides are now blaming each
other for um for starting
the this clash uh lebanon is a country
that has seen confrontations in the past
there has never really been peace and
stability since the end of the civil war
in 1990 but like i said the issue of the
investigation into the bay report
explosion has really divided this
country and polarized this country even
further all right zayna let me um ask
them in a situation like this of course
things are not always immediately very
clear but it's important for us to try
and be a little bit as forensic as
possible as we can to try and paint the
picture and an understanding of what's
going on so first of all when you you
said an rpg
that's of course a rocket-propelled
grenade usually an anti-tank weapon
was fired do we have any idea who was
firing
it's hard to say we've been asking the
army and the internal security forces
here they are saying they are saying
that
they don't know the source of the
gunfire they don't know who's firing uh
the rpg but i can't let me ask this
question
who party is the idea that they somebody
was firing at the protesters who've been
gathering in beirut today were they the
target is that what it appears is going
on
we're getting conflicting reports an
army official was quoted as saying that
there was a sniper that fired into um
into a crowd of army soldiers other
reports suggest that they fire towards
protesters as you can imagine the
situation is very fluid right now people
are panicking they're heading home we
haven't been able to confirm even um you
know
who where exactly that sniper was
they're saying that uh this sniper was
in tayuni and in fact many people here
are telling us don't go down that road
don't go down the road there are a lot
of snipers there there's just a lot of
tension here and this this issue
over the port blast has has divided this
country yesterday we heard the
opposition accuse hezbollah and amal the
shia political groups that called for
the demonstration today of carrying out
a coup of of carrying out a coup against
the state a coup against the judiciary
and to really impose its will on the
lebanese people with the threat of arms
and
in fact
hezbollah and amal they have been
warning of civil strife if
the
investigation continues um according to
to its path so right now
it's very hard to see how a compromise
can be reached in the past um
when we have been in situations like
this uh some sort of a compromise is
reached between the different political
you can still hear the bursts of of
gunfire uh
yeah and that was another louder
explosion that most likely was a
rocket-propelled grenade sammy the rpg
that we talked about earlier so
if you can see the army
have a heavy security deployment in in
the streets they are directing traffic
making sure that people do not drive uh
towards tayuni the area of tayuni like i
mentioned that is has long been a front
line in fact last night we understand
there was tension there
there was tension when supporters of the
different political parties were in the
streets um
yes it's dangerous times this is a
dangerous dangerous escalation in in the
situation
and lebanon
there's it's not just an escalation on
the streets there's also political
escalation there is a real possibility
of um political paralysis
just last month a new government was
was formed after 13 months of deadlock
and now amal and hezbollah are
threatening to quit the cabinet if judge
is not removed and i think i have to
mention uh why they are insisting that
judge batar is dismissed
they say that he is politicized and that
he is going after a specific individuals
now judge bittar this investigation
is a secret he has not answered to those
claims but supporters of bittar who
include i must mention the families of
the victims of the beirut court
explosion believe that he is doing the
right thing that he is on the right path
and that he is one of the rare judges
who is not politically affiliated
because in this country
the judiciary is
is accused of not being politically
independent okay
let me let me jump in and ask you what's
going on around you there uh first of
all just to clarify are you close to the
area where the the demonstrations were
taking place
yes let me show you if we could just
walk this way to our right was where uh
the demonstration was taking place
that's the justice palace uh to our left
just a few hundred meters from here is
tayuni where we understand the people
were shot at by a sniper again this
hasn't been confirmed according to an
army official we are trying to to
confirm exactly what happened and that
is why uh people are avoiding uh
driving down towards tyuni because what
we unders we just heard an rpg being
fired a short while ago okay so zaina
let me then jump in and ask
there was a demonstration further down
that road to the right and we've got
reports of shootings happening also
further down to that road but on the
left and behind you we could see
soldiers stopping people one assumes
that this is a security fan out
operation and soldiers now trying to
control this whole area where there's
demonstrations and reports of shooting
going on
but i must mention um the protesters
have since uh left the area
approximately an hour an hour and a half
ago after the repeated bursts of gunfire
there you hear another loud explosion it
seems this is not just only automatic uh
rifles that are being used but
rocket-propelled grenades as well uh
people
maybe if somebody
maybe we can ask somebody coming from
that direction to give us more
information it is quite difficult now
to venture down that road without
knowing
the lay of the land at this point in
time when can it enter
ah
people people are worried they're
they're hearing gunfire they don't know
what is going on um sorry afford sorry
it's we're going to try to find out sami
what is happening
down that road
to see whether or not maybe we can
approach the ambulance let's let's go
down that road yes sammy just to put it
in context zayna the protesters today
we're in open air we should be on the
right yes and we can hear the gunfight
going on yes sammy yes i'm just pausing
for a second to let us take in the
sounds
that we can hear
but yeah i was saying
the protesters today they were
supporters of hezbollah and ammo two
predominantly shiite groups which want
to see this judge step down right those
were the protesters were on the streets
did we have any rival demonstrators from
from people who want to see the judge
stay in his position
not today sammy not today but over the
past year or so since that uh port
explosion the families of the victims as
well as um
other lebanese have been taken to the
streets demanding justice demanding
accountability it has been a troubled
investigation uh since since the start
batar judge batar is the second judge to
have been appointed the first judge was
also removed by the political class
really the standoff between
the establishment and vitar
began in july when he started
summoning former and current ministers
to be questioned and he wanted to
question them as suspects they are being
accused of criminal negligence he says
that there is evidence that they were
aware of the ammonium nitrate in
warehouse 12 being stored unsafely with
flammable materials and they did nothing
about it they did not do they did not do
their jobs so they were criminally
neglect but those politicians these
former ministers
refused to show up for questioning and
every time um at the beginning they had
parliamentary immunity but two weeks ago
parliament was in recess so they lost
their immunity and bittar the judge
tried to take advantage of of this this
situation and to call them in for
questioning so they're refusing to
cooperate the establishment and
hezbollah want him to be dismissed and
those in the opposition groups like the
christian lebanese forces which really
their stronghold isn't tayuni facing
amal and they have really been accused
by some of amaz supporters of deploying
those snipers um support judge batar and
in fact the leader of the christian
lebanese forces party said last night
samir sharjah he did say that hezbollah
cannot impose its will on us that
eventually if they take to the streets
we too can take uh to the streets so
there was really a lot of tension in the
run-up uh to today's protest and
there these the political divide
it has been in has been in place for
years now so it just takes
an incident
for
um a confrontation or a a clash to
happen
so
as you can see tension
in the streets we are trying to confirm
the source who's the who was the source
of gunfire it's still not clear zayna as
you're talking let me point out for
viewers we've got pictures on the right
side of the screen you may not be able
to see but we had pictures there
of what looked like army
apcs being deployed
do you get a feeling that the army is
now in control of the streets
to a certain extent but still
down what i told you the front line is
still unclear because we're still
hearing bursts of
automatic gunfire but we're getting some
reports that the army is saying that uh
yeah this is this the army on how the
violence began protesters were heading
to beirut's justice palace where um they
were shot at so according to this line
the protesters were shot at in the area
of tayuni badaro that front line that i
keep on mentioning that that fault line
between
the christian lebanese
forces party and the shia amal party and
the army moved in to
cordon off the area and arrest
the the shooters
it's
it's a fluid situation the army
has been out in force
and as we know now the latest in terms
of casualties one dead eight wounded in
the beirut rally that has been organized
by hezbollah so
um a city on edge sammy a city on edge i
i could i am assuming that there will be
behind the scenes contacts between the
different political factions because it
is in no one's interest for the
situation to descend into a chaos uh
this could be a an intimidating tactic
on the part of these different political
parties to ensure that their demands are
met um it's too early to say we can keep
on speculating but but right now i can
show you a lot of people are saying that
we don't even know what's going on
because we don't have electricity in our
homes to watch television uh the kind of
the economy has all but collapsed the
state doesn't uh provide power for more
than an hour or two hours a day and
more than 80 percent of the population
is now poor so they have no money to
afford private generators so the
lebanese people are tired um
this is they've lived years
the past few years have been very
difficult
not only economic turmoil political
turmoil a lot of people are telling you
we're packing our bags and leaving
because of the dire economic conditions
and i can tell you after this incident a
lot more will
will decide to to leave this country so
what we understand a sniper opens fire
at protesters who were making their way
to the justice palace we're still
waiting for more official statements
from the different political factions
but right now this is what we have but
we are seeing a lot of video on social
media of um you know men carrying
weapons um
it's it doesn't bode well really for the
for for the future of this country which
has had a turbulent and dark past every
so often there is bouts of violence that
that makes
people have little faith let me try to
ask these motor
sorry when can it enter wink in it
okay he's saying that there's a lot of
sorry
there's a lot of army presence in in the
front line
he saw a lot of men armed men in the
streets
one
most of the gunfire they were firing
into the air
three or four uh rpgs were fired we
heard that those loud explosions
i'm asking him how does he feel is the
lebanese perhaps it might be
interesting to ask him if he saw who was
actually doing the shooting were they
rival protesters or is he referring to
army personnel
no
no not the army personnel he was talking
about armed
[Music]
he's saying i don't support anybody
because in this country almost everybody
is politicized he's saying that there
were armed men from the shia amal party
they were opening fire basement
it's very hard sammy to ask such a
question to a to a lebanese who mostly
everybody belongs to or supports a
certain political party so it's very um
we have to be careful uh because it's
hard to say clearly
we don't know what happened we are
waiting for official statements from
both sides but what i can tell you is
that that is a front line a very known
front line every time there's a
political crisis in this country every
time there's a bout of bouts of violence
it happens there and that's when the
army is always deployed now he said the
army is deployed so i think we may be
able to approach the area now um
[Applause]
there's
she ran away she wants to head home but
she doesn't know which way how how she's
going to be able to get home which road
to take okay
um
yeah people
so you know the lebanese um are just
concerned they're confused they they
don't know what is happening well
in a way they do these are let's put
into context of violence let's put into
context then what we've learned so far
because i think the narrative has
developed
over the last 20 minutes that we've been
on air talking about this
so there's there was obviously a
demonstration going on there was a
procession of it trying to reach the
presidential palace
and then we've had reports of somebody
some armed guys shooting right and the
result of this is one person's killed
eight people have been wounded and the
demonstration has been dispersed
the demonstration has been dismerged
dispersed approximately two hours ago
they were outside the justice palace uh
protesting against the lead judge
investigating the beirut port explosion
demanding that he be dismissed now the
lebanese army has just issued a
statement saying that they will shoot at
any armed person on the street shooting
from any place and that they have asked
the people to leave the streets and to
leave near the site of the clashes now
that's exactly where we are near the
site of the clashes we are approaching
uh slowly uh because clearly we do not
know what is up ahead we are going to
stay on our side in case that they
continue firing rocket-propelled
grenades which at least three have been
fired over the past past hour so the
army now issuing this terse statement
saying that they will fire back the army
is in a very very difficult position i
think it's very important to talk about
the role of the army in lebanon this is
the only institution which is seen to a
certain extent as neutral standing
really on the sidelines every time there
is a political a political conflict
because the army is made up of
of of the different sects in this
country and if the army does side with
one political party against another then
the risk is it will split um
which happened really during the civil
war in the 1980s when the army split
um so this is where the danger is right
now it is the lebanese army which is the
only one keeping this country you cannot
be seen
so basically they're advising us not to
venture any further because there are a
lot of snipers on rooftops they're
saying also that uh the lebanese army
has a heavy presence in the air zayna do
we need to let you go to take cover it
seemed those guys in the car were
warning you there is snipers close to
you i'm a bit concerned they told us not
to not to venture
sorry when can it enter
uh
still they haven't contained the
situation yet he is saying that the army
is in the middle and there's still
sniper fire saw in english
is a neighborhood uh the stronghold of
amal and ayna rameni is a stronghold of
the christian lebanese forces party
intel you're a sahafi writer a
journalist
are you shocked that this is happening
today or you expected this
he said since he was born it's the same
scene he's seen over and over again and
this is what we've been trying to say
this country has not seen stability and
security um the the war the civil war
ended was 30 years ago now but this is
continuous the different political
parties the different leaders today were
former warlords and the struggle for
power really continues and the lebanese
people are trapped in the middle but
thank you thank you and we will try to
see there's the
okay their army
maybe we can ask them whether or not we
can
to you and our viewers we're now hearing
from hospital sources that two people
have been killed
you don't think so why
oh okay the army does not speak to
journalists
uh he's also intelligence they will not
speak to us they're not allowed to speak
to reporters so
as you heard that journalist it's a
scene that the lebanese people have seen
over and over again streets are empty
everyone is back home worried about what
happens next in a country where the
economy has all but collapsed in a
country where
the currency has collapsed losing 90
percent of its value over the past two
years the government should be meeting
the government should be um it's a bit
open air space here ali we should walk
ahead for the walls come um so the
currency has lost its value uh people's
minimum wage now worthless people's
deposits are also trapped in banks
because banks are unable to
uh
banks are unable to or are refusing to
give
their depositors back their money so
this country has many many problems and
now the government is paralyzed they
were supposed to begin negotiations with
the international monetary fund
for a bailout package that has not begun
so until this issue this issue over over
of the investigation into
over the investigation
let's just walk here so that we're next
to the wall
um
zayn let's let's come back if we can to
what's what's going on now
and that uh
journalist you were talking to from what
we could gather from that
conversation there seems to be an
indication of exchange of fire between
two different neighborhoods going on or
buildings in two different neighborhoods
a shia which is a predominantly
shiite muslim neighborhood an aina
ramana
which is predominantly
lebanese christian forces
neighborhood right and i mean if that's
the picture
how worrying and disturbing is that
because
does that not bring our memories back to
the lebanese civil war exchanges of fire
in 1975
[Applause]
true
this was the front line
in 1975 when the civil war broke out
and at times um and this is not the
first time that there has been violence
along this fault line since the end of
the war in 1990 these are two political
parties but long-time enemies the
leaders of both of these political
parties were former warlords uh during
the war
and
clearly the divide is deep there's
sectarian tensions in this country
um
you you heard the man we've seen this
time and time again he says he's not
shocked uh possibly we'll wake up
tomorrow morning as if this nothing
happened the leaders will sit together
on the table call each other behind the
scenes and reach some sort of a solution
to the latest crisis and life goes on
instead of solving the core problem in
this country which is the lack of
national unity and the lack of national
reconciliation
between the people which allows these
politicians and
leaders of political parties to exploit
those grievances in order to remain in
power we have to remember two years ago
there was a protest movement a
non-sectarian mass protest movement
nationwide uh
i'm just asking them fishy horn
honla
adam schwai
huh
okay we're gonna keep walking sammy
sorry but we just have to ask
um
sure
we appreciate you gathering information
on the fly for us like this
yes so there was this protest movement
which has largely fizzled out now
demanding a change in leadership
demanding uh new faces because they
blame the political class which has been
governing this this country for three
decades now for
for really running the economy into the
ground
blaming them
for corruption mismanagement the state
is nearly bankrupt i think it's
important always i think it's important
to say that this
the state no longer
has has any
foreign currency reserves to keep on
importing fuel you've seen scenes from
beirut over recent weeks of uh
of the fuel crisis the long queues at
gas stations uh so the people of this
country are dealing with daily struggles
uh to to put food on the table to
secure electricity even hospital
hospitalization people can no longer
afford to pay for hospitalization fees
because they're now so poor and their
currency has lost value so it seems
they're still evacuating some wounded
we're gonna go to the other side of the
street because
i think we should be on the other side
because yeah
um
yes sammy uh so we are approaching
the front line now you can see more
maybe explain to us saying an hour
you've been walking in that direction
for a little bit
where exactly are you going are you
heading towards the area between
shia and aina romana where apparently
there were reports of exchange of fire
yes
you can still hear the birds of
automatic gunfire okay that was a sniper
that's a sniper we have to ali come back
here
[Applause]
okay
so
we have to move back a bit let's stay
behind this wall guys so you can see
come here
okay just stay here
okay okay but uh so zayna you're now
literally very close to the area where
we can actually not only believe but
where we can hear gunfire still being
exchanged right now
correct
sniper fire yes sniper fire according to
the lebanese army that is what they told
us now that's why they told us to move
back because it's not clear where it is
coming from uh there are high buildings
up ahead down this road
the front line or what we can call that
fault line is just a few hundred meters
in front of us the army like i mentioned
earlier issued a statement saying that
they're going to shoot at anybody who is
armed
this will take a while to contain
this has happened in the past it's not
easy
for the army to move in and and you know
the army has to be very careful not to
be seen as taking sides we talked about
the lebanese army a while ago uh before
we spoke i believe to the journalists or
to the army personnel they're in a very
difficult position because if they take
any action against one political party
instead of another it really risks the
armies the army's unity which has
happened in in the past um
let me ask you this i know
this is a very unclear and fluid
situation but the journalist in you
still has to ask the question even
though i i understand it's going to be
difficult to sort it out do we have any
idea who the snipers are shooting at if
demonstrators have been dispersed
it's hard to say it's hard to say
but if you ask
the uh so the demonstrators the
protesters who belong to the shia
political groups amalan hezbollah what
they were telling us at the site of the
demonstration earlier outside the
justice palace they were pointing the
finger at the lebanese forces the
christian lebanese forces of course um
we cannot independently confirm this the
army is saying that uh it was you know
the shooting was carried out by snipers
this is according uh to the to the to
the army like we mentioned earlier and
at least now we're getting reports that
two people have been killed not one and
at least 20 injured now
we also know that all roads leading to
aina romani are now closed the army what
the army trade is trying to do now
before
before moving in is trying to isolate
these two neighborhoods from each other
to actually push the armed men on both
sides of the divide further back this
before they will be able uh to move in
so you can see people leaving the area
people of course will be
will are afraid they're afraid
whether or not
tomorrow morning everything will go back
to normal or
if
indeed this this will this will worsen
uh whether or not this will be contained
in the past situations like this have
been have been contained uh but there's
no saying so now we are hearing from the
lebanese red cross
okay
lebanese red cross two there are 20
injured so that's the casualty told
right now
all right
all right zayna we're gonna we're gonna
let you take a break and take some cover
here i'm sure we're gonna come back to
you soon but that's zena khoda reporting
to us in a very fluid and dangerous
situation in beirut the lebanese capital
two people reportedly killed
dozens more injured